we promoted a culture where our laws
would be upheld
our heroes honored our history preserved
and law abiding citizens are never taken
for granted
lil wayne and kodak black are in the
clear thanks to president donald trump
but tiger king star joe exotic no such
luck
according to a statement released by the
white house the rappers were included in
the final wave of
pardons and commutations granted by
trump on tuesday
his last full day in office wayne
pleaded guilty last month to
illegally carrying a loaded handgun
while traveling to florida on a private
plane in december 2019
according to cbs news he was set to face
up to 10 years in prison
at a hearing in miami on january 28th
i see the change i see the message and
no message could have been
any clearer so i'm starting with the man
lil wayne appeared to support trump
during his 2020 presidential campaign
even tweeting a pic of himself with the
president praising the politicians
criminal justice reform program and
economic plan for african americans
as for black cbs news reported that he
was sentenced in november 2019
to nearly four years in prison on
federal weapons charges
he pleaded guilty in august 2019 to two
counts of
knowingly making a false and fictitious
written statement in order to
unlawfully acquire firearms but one
person trump
didn't pardon hey i'm joe exotic
otherwise known as a tiger king
yeah joe exotic didn't make the cut he
might have shut me up for just a little
while but let me tell you they've awoken
a monster
the tiger king star is currently serving
a 22-year sentence in a fort worth texas
federal prison
for his conviction on charges that he
participated in a murder for hire plot
and
violated federal wildlife laws i am
supposed to be in this country
born raised innocent until proven guilty
and i have been stripped of my clothes
my rights
my identity my dignity back in september
the tiger king star submitted a
handwritten letter calling trump his
hero
oh and his legal argument for a pardon
was that he was quote
just some gay gun-toting redneck in
oklahoma before his recent netflix
fame and that he didn't get a fair trial
of course all this comes just hours
before wednesday's inauguration of
president-elect
joe biden this week we inaugurate a
new administration and pray for its
success
in keeping america safe and prosperous
we extend our best wishes and we also
want them
to have luck a very important word
on wednesday morning hours after he
pardoned 73 people
trump left washington d.c aboard air
force one for one
final time as president and gave a few
final remarks at a farewell celebration
at joint base andrews before
jetting off to florida most of all i
want to thank the american people
to serve as your president has been an
honor
beyond description thank you for
this extraordinary privilege
you